bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre en direct
les questions cribles thématiques
consacré cette semaine à la forêt
française alors les questions cribles
thématiques vous le savez c'est cette
série de questions posées par les
sénateurs à un membre du gouvernement
sur un thème spécifique cette semaine il
s'adresse à carole delga secrétaire
d'état au commerce et à l'artisanat à
propos de la forêt française alors pour
vous situer la forêt française
chaque année 80 millions d'arbres sont
plantés en france soit plus de deux
arbres par seconde les chiffres sont
édifiants ce sont les chiffres du
ministère du développement durable et la
surface des forêts a doublé depuis 1850
le secteur de la forêt française recrute
directement environ 300000 personnes et
indirectement beaucoup plus biodiversité
lutte contre le changement climatique
poids économique les enjeux et les
questions pour les sénateurs ne manquent
pas pour vous situer toujours la forêt
la france est le troisième pays européen
par sa surface forestière devant après
la suède pardon et la finlande et la
france est le premier producteur
européen de chêne de hêtre et de
peuplier alors les questions d'actualité
vont donner la parole à neuf
intervenants différents les questions
cribles thématiques vous le savez c'est
un exercice qui a été instaurée par
gérard larcher et qui devrait être
bientôt supprimer tout de suite
direction les questions cribles et votre
séance elles vont être posées à madame
carole delga secrétaire d'état chargé du
commerce de l'artisanat la consommation
de l'économie sociale et solidaire et
elle porte sur la forêt et notamment la
forêt française bien sûr
la séance est retransmise en direct sur
france 3 et public saidal pour ouvrir à
l'orée du bois en quelque sorte la
parole est à monsieur alain houpert pour
le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire vous avez la parole on série
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues lui la forêt obscure
et j'espère qu'après nos interventions
elle sera percée de rais de lumière
si mon collègue yannick botrel et moi
même avons rendu le mois dernier au nom
de la commission des finances un rapport
intitulé faire de la filière bois un
atout pour la france c'est parce que
notre pays n'est pas la puissance
forestière qu'elle pourrait être notre
travail
appuyé sur une enquête de la cour des
comptes a permis de démontrer que la
politique forestière et tour est
aujourd'hui sans stratégie sans pilote
et sans résultat les cinq ministères qui
met en oeuvre un ou plusieurs volets de
cette politique concernant la filière
adapte chacun dans son coin
une vision des enjeux qui lui est propre
ma première question madame la ministre
est issu de ce constat qu'en et selon
quelles modalités
allez vous construire un lieu de
concertation et de décision
interministérielle pour cette filière il
s'agit d'une urgence impérative pour la
construction d'un pilotage stratégique
de la filière ce qui constitue la
première de nos recommandations
par ailleurs la france a fait le choix
d'un modèle économique de pays en
développement réfléter par les graves
déséquilibres entre l'exportation de
bois brut et l'importation de produits
transformés
c'est cette situation qui conduit à un
déficit commercial de la filière de 6
milliards d'euros par an soit 10 % du
déficit total de notre balance
commerciale
quelles mesures le gouvernement entente
il prendre pour rétablir l'équilibré
économique de la filière
et quel regard portez vous sur les sept
recommandations que yannick botrel et
moi même avons formulé dans notre
rapport
je souhaite la ministre plus
particulièrement recevoir vos réactions
sur l'eau cette préoccupation rapprocher
les interprofessions et autre organisme
professionnel tourné lohan s vers une
logique de performance et de résultats
et enfin rire réoriente
les aides à laval en stabilisant les
soutiens en bois énergie mais en
soutenant davantage le bois d'oeuvre et
particulièrement le secteur de
l'ameublement médine france en bref
madame la ministre
comment en tête des vous faire enfin de
la filière bois un atout pour la france
merci de votre réponse mais aussi pour
vous répondre la parole et à madame la
ministre vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur alain houpert
je voudrais tout d'abord excusé stéphane
le foll qui aurait aimé pouvoir être
présents pour répondre à vos questions
néanmoins il a dû se rendre au g20
agricole qui se tient à istanbul cet
après midi et demain également
je souhaite au nom du gouvernement salué
la qualité des travaux de la cour des
comptes et souligné l'intérêt d'avoir
par le biais de ce rapport une vision
d'ensemble des soutiens financiers
apportiez à la filière bois
je souhaite également rappeler que le
rapport porte sur la période 2006 2013
et que la cour reconnaît d'ores et déjà
des avancées depuis 2012 dans la
politique menée par ce gouvernement
s'agissant de la gouvernance de la
filière forêt bois la loi d'avenir pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et la forêt
promulguée le 13 octobre 2014 a été
l'occasion de rénover les structures de
gouvernance autour du conseil supérieur
de la forêt et du bois
ce conseil dispose en effet de
compétences couvrant l'ensemble des
fonctions sociales économiques et
environnementales de la forêt et des
produits forestiers et réunit l'ensemble
des acteurs impliqués public et privé la
loi de venir prévoit également qu une
stratégie de filière sera défini au
niveau national au travers du programme
national de la forêt du bois
ce dernier est en cours d'élaboration
mais l'ensemble des acteurs si travaux
reprennent en particulier l'ensemble des
orientations adoptées le 16 décembre
dernier dans le contrat de filière au
sein du comité stratégique de filière à
dossier au conseil national de
l'industrie
le contrat de filière est caractérisé
par son interminable
d'interministérialité et comme vous
l'avez souligné cela est indispensable
alors que la cour des comptes souligne
souvent le manque de travail
interministériel dans les politiques
pour la forêt et le bois ces dernières
années
ce contrat est né un effet été signé par
la ministre chargée de l'écologie et de
l'énergie
le ministre chargé des forêts le
ministre chargé de l'industrie et la
ministre chargé du logement
cette stratégie de leurs cotisants sera
ensuite déclinée en région concernant
les sept propositions bien entendu
stéphane le foll et ses collaborateurs
n'hésiteront pas à les examiner et vous
apporter des réponses point par point
merci madame le ministre pour répondre
la ministre en 40 secondes
monsieur opère merci madame la ministre
vous parler de la gouvernance il faut
effectivement là un choc de
simplification et puis vous concernant
le contrat de filière
nous souhaitons qu'il y ait plus dead en
aval pour faire en sorte que nous ayons
des produits bois made in france merci
pour monsieur houpert merci la parole
est à monsieur alain bertrand pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen vous avez la parole mon
cher collègue mais c'est le président
madame la ministre chers collègues et
vendront aussi sa porte sur la forêt
et
bon
j'aurais pu parler de la pêche à la
ligne
c'est que le président du sénat année
d'un expert nom de la forêt et de la
filière bois
bon si l'avenir l'avenir le dis tout
depuis il ya des rapports en pagaille
qui met en évidence cette ressource
notamment comme le levier des
territoires ruraux et ip ruraux pour
créer des emplois et de la valeur
ajoutée
d'autres très correctement je veux
m'appuyer sur le cas que je connais un
peu et celui de la forêt lozérienne qui
ne fait pas que recéler des cèpes
dédicaces et autres volatiles la fille
ni à boire à près de 2000 emplois lozère
monsieur le président madame la ministre
elle est plutôt bien structuré elle nous
permet contrairement à certains
départements phase i de transformer
localement de la majeure partie des
coupes lozérienne cependant on constate
mais on ça fait des années qu'on le
constate qu' on ne pouvait mieux
utiliser le bois
bon les différentes zones existantes
montrent en effet une évolution
qualitative positive de la forêt à la
fin des années 90 j'avais dit gamme 8%
des bois a été vendue pour le chauffage
76 % étaient destinés à la première
transformation sans grande valeur
ajoutée et 16% seulement deuxième
transformation avec de la valeur ajoutée
et la de l'emploi surtout aujourd'hui on
estime que 20 % du bois vendus est
destiné à cette deuxième transformation
et que d'ici quelques années en devenir
et rate de demain ce sera 30 % euros des
bois lozériens qui seront commercialisés
qui pourront donner lieu à cette
deuxième transformation
là je donc c'est la transformation le
bois construction et l'adaptation de
cette petite industrie à cette ressource
qui devient plus favorable
c'est une question majeure à sacha que
la deuxième transformation c'est 10 fois
plus d'emplois
ce serait donc monsieur le président
madame la ministre des dizaines et des
centaines d'emplois supplémentaires dans
chacun des départements ip ruraux et
forestiers mais ya plusieurs problèmes
le forestier nationalement les problèmes
qui n'existent plus qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant une baisse de production du
bois construction parce qu on replante
pas donc madame la ministre
quelle est la destination des pme de la
filière
deuxième transformation et quelle est la
stratégie du gouvernement de l'état
français pour favoriser l'investissement
forestier et préparer ainsi la création
de milliers d'emplois dans nos petits
départements vous restiez c'est très
simple merci mon cher collègue la parole
et à madame lavigne
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur alain bertrand
comme je l'indiquais tout à l'heure le
contrat stratégique de filière bois
signé par quatre ministres a permis de
définir un cadre et au travers de ce
contrat nous avons proposé une large
gamme d'actions tout d'abord la mise en
place d'outils de pilotage et
d'élaboration de stratégies la
structuration du segment industriel et
du tissu entrepreunarial la promotion et
le développement des emplois de la
filière bois la compétitivité par
l'innovation de nos entreprises
le marketing le design également pour
mieux vendre nos produits bois à
l'export et en france l'adaptation de
l'offre la première transformation aux
besoins des marchés
la seconde transformation et la sécurité
des approvisionnements en bois de la
filière concernant les financements vous
rappeler que le fonds bois 2 est en
cours de constitution consacrée aux
investissements dans les outils de
transformation
la participation de bpi france est déjà
acquise à hauteur de 25 millions d'euros
et la recherche de financements privés
est en cours concernant les financements
les épaules investissements forestiers
la création du fonds stratégique de la
forêt et du bois dans l enveloppe
atteindra à terme 30 millions d'euros va
être combiné avec l'extension du fonds
chaleur à la mobilisation du bois
énergie
il a pour la première fois en 2015 30
millions d'euros sont consacrés afin de
permettre justement l'alimentation du
bois pour le dispositif du d énergie à
travers l'utilisation du bois et nous
avons également souhaité mettre en place
un nouveau compte d'investissements
forestiers et d'assurance qui permettra
à travers ces mesures fiscales de
dynamiser la mobilisation est aussi de
soutenir la transformation du bois sur
notre territoire
gage de création d'emplois dans les
territoires ruraux également hyperburo
comme vous sont chers
merci chers collègues pour répliquer aux
ministres entrants me souviens je
remercie et monsieur le ministre
l'agriculture d'ensemble de ces
précisions
c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai dispositif
une vraie stratégie je solliciterai
madame la ministre que les préfets
soient un peu les chefs d'orchestre et
stratégies sur le territoire pour
répondre aussi bien aux investisseurs
privés que publics et aux entrepreneurs
de telle manière que les entrepreneurs
et face à eux une espèce de guichet
unique qui lui permettent de savoir
toutes les cordes de notre art dispose
pour mettre en valeur en fait nos forêts
et nos entreprises forestières et si
créer de l'emploi dont la réponse ne
satisfait mais sur l'aspect fonctionnel
faisons encore des progrès parce que nos
entrepreneurs sont un peu perdus non
propriétaires forestiers aussi merci mon
cher collègue
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
joël labbé pour le groupe écologiste
avait la parole merci monsieur le
président si le président madame la
ministre
chères et chers collègues nous nous
retrouvons aujourd'hui pour cette
session de questions cribles thématiques
sur la forêt française
nous avons pris connaissance comme vous
toutes et vous tous du rapport de nos
collègues de la commission des finances
intitulé faire de la filière bois un
atout pour la france
si les fortes intéressant du point de
vue du diagnostic je déplore que ce
rapport aborde dans ses recommandations
la problématique de la forêt française
essentiellement d'une manière comptable
il recommande notamment une
recomposition de la france de la forêt
vers les résultats au regard de la
demande
cette approche comptable de court terme
doit être revue afin de prendre en
compte
certes les aspects économiques qui ont
leur importance aussi pour nous
écologique aux écologistes
évidemment mais aussi les aspects
écologiques notamment la biodiversité le
stockage naturel de carbone on doit
envisager d'innover en associant des
essences à plus haute valeur ajoutée
économique et en cela également
renforçant les aménités environnementale
il est grand temps de repenser la forêt
comme milieu vivant dans toutes ses
diversités de remettre en cause les
coupes à blanc systématique nuisible
pour les sols et leur structure est très
émettrices de carbone
la qualité et la santé de nos forêts
auront tout à y gagner une parcelle
forestière gérées durablement permettent
au sol de jouer son rôle de puits de
carbone objectifs attachés par la france
notamment par son ministre de
l'agriculture en vue de la coque 21 au
travers du projet de recherche
international 4 pour 1000 dont
l'objectif est de développer la
recherche agronomique afin d'améliorer
les stocks de matière organique des sols
de 4 pour 1000 par an et une telle
augmentation à l'échelle mondiale
permettrait de compenser l'ensemble des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de la
planète c'est dire si la forêt végétal
et le sol de cette forêt ont un rôle
essentiel à jouer
madame la ministre pouvait ne pouvez
vous nous indiquer quelle est la
position du gouvernement français
concernant la gestion des forêts
françaises afin de garantir une
cohérence de l'exploitation et une
amélioration des aménités
environnementale en terme de
biodiversité et de stockage de carbone
dans les sols forestiers je vous
remercie
merci vous chers collègues pour vous
répondre la parole et rnm la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur la baie je tiens à vous
rassurer la gestion durable et le
principe de base qui guide la politique
forestière nationale dans le respect de
nos engagements européens et
internationaux
la récente loi d'avenir a d'ailleurs
rappelé ce principe un reconnaissance
d'intérêt général la protection et la
mise en valeur des bois et forêts ainsi
que le reboisement dans le cadre d'une
gestion durable
l'importance des aménités de la forêt
que ce soit en terme de biodiversité de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
ou de fonction récréative sont
régulièrement réaffirmée le programme
national de la forêt du bois en cours
d'élaboration en sera la traduction
concrète pour les dix prochaines années
pour autant il ne faut pas perdre de vue
qu'à ce jour seule la production de bois
et la chasse sont génératrices de roche
de recettes et permettent aux
propriétaires publics ou privés
d'entretenir la forêt et d'y investir
la forêt n'a jamais cessé d'être pensé
comme un milieu vivant la coupe rase
oies blanches ne signifie pas forcément
destruction de biodiversité ou à provis
appauvrissement des sols
il est question de mesure il est
question de savoir bien gérer la forêt
concernant les enjeux climatiques
que la forêt l'agriculture seront au
coeur des négociations de la prochaine
coupe 21 c'est la volonté affirmée à
plusieurs reprises par stéphane le foll
la forêt le secteur des terres ont un
rôle très important à jouer dans
l'atteinte des objectifs ambitieux de
réduction d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre la dynamisation de la sylviculture
objectif partagé par france nature
environnement et l'agronomie peuvent
fortement contribué à l'atteinte de
sauvetage de cet objectif
c'est dans ce but que stéphane le foll a
initié un programme de recherche et
d'action international 4 pour mille sur
le constat suivant une augmentation de 4
millièmes de la teneur en matière
organique des sols permettrait de
compenser les émissions annuelles
mondiales de co2 en fait le programme
national de la forêt du bois devra
trouver trouver l'équilibré entre le nez
la nécessaire valorisation économique de
notre patrimoine forestier très
largement sous-exploité 20 à 30% de la
production annuelle seulement prélevé et
la préservation de la biodiversité et
autres fonctions environnementales de
nos forêts comme par exemple les
curation de l'eau nous serons donc mieux
mobiliser attentif pour la gestion
durable de l'ensemble de nos forêts aux
répondants milices monsieur l'abbé en 30
secondes
oui madame la ministre votre réponse est
claire donc merci pour vos
éclaircissements
ces éclaircissements nécessaires lorsque
la forêt devient trop étouffante
beaucoup d'aspects n'ont pas été abordés
concernant les enjeux liés à l'arbre et
la forêt la préservation et l'entretien
de la haie bocagère qui joue un rôle
essentiel
le développement de l'agroforesterie et
enfin un domaine essentiel qui fait la
grande richesse de notre patrimoine
forestier et dont on parle trop peu nos
forêts primaires équatoriale en
conclusion n'oublions pas que la gestion
forestière est du domaine du temps long
que la forêt vivante puis sedan son
profond silence et dans l'immensité de
son mystère nous réapprendre ce que son
patience et longueur de temps
merci petit c'est du baudelaire
j'appelle maintenant
madame la vice présidente françoise
cartron pour le groupe socialiste vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre michelle
collègues voté à la rentrée 2014 et la
loi d'avenir pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et la forêt est venu
renouveler la gouvernance de notre
politique forestière avec une ambition
que le secteur forestier soit reconnue
enfin pour ce qu'il est à savoir une
composante économique et social
essentiel à l' équilibre des territoires
alors que plusieurs rapports en dresser
un bilan et un bilan très mitigé de la
filière bois en france le gouvernement
n'a pas attendu pour agir afin de
renforcer la compétitivité de la filière
le plan national de la forêt du bois
viendra définir dans un cadre
stratégique pour la filière sur le long
terme
madame la ministre ce plan national qui
sera finalisé prochainement avec une
déclinaison régionale doit redynamiser
l'exploitation forestière de la forêt
privée en encourageant la
contractualisation afin notamment de
sécuriser les approvisionnements de
l'industrie du sciage
c'est une avancée reconnu nous nous
félicitons également de la signature
comme vous l'avez souligné par quatre
ministres du contrat de filière bois le
16 décembre dernier qui a permis de
réunir autour d'une même table
l'ensemble des grands acteurs de la
filière pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
une véritable stratégie à long terme
mais hier sur le salon des élus locaux
d'aquitaine auxquels vous étiez monsieur
le président j'ai été interpellé sur la
problématique des petites et moyennes
syrie dont la survie aujourd'hui remise
en cause en gironde et dans les landes
tout particulièrement madame la ministre
pourriez-vous réaffirmé la détermination
du gouvernement à soutenir les seigneurs
locaux dont les capacités financières
sont limitées notamment par rapport aux
grands groupes pas petit internationaux
merci
le président même la ministre vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la vice présidente françoise
cartron le secteur de la première
transformation du bois koné et même
évolution que l'agriculture avec une
baisse continue du nombre de syrie est
une tendance à la concentration avec la
création de grosses unités
surtout en résine depuis 30 ans la série
française a ainsi perdu chaque année une
centaine d'unités soit près de 3500 en
particulier en feuillus alors que notre
massif est très majoritairement venus
les raisons les plus souvent évoquées de
cette concentration par les
professionnels sont l'absence de
repreneur
les problèmes de succession le manque de
rentabilité les contraintes
administratives et normatives les
scieries artisanale restent majoritaires
60% des installations mais pour
seulement 7 % du volume de sièges
produits 18% de cire et industriels
représentent 30 de 17% du volume de
sièges produits nos plus grands ceux ci
résineuses reste toutefois dans la
moyenne des unités allemandes ou
autrichiennes en marge des grandes
couronnes d'affaires le secteur
artisanal des petites et moyennes séries
tire son épingle du jeu en s'employant
dans le sur mesure demandée par les
artisans les négoces de ville où les
particuliers de plus en plus nombreux il
faut s'atteler à maintenir cette
dynamique le maintien d'un tissu de
syrie de toutes dimensions est important
et essentiel pour le maintien de
l'activité dans nos territoires ruraux
et pour l'économie de l'ensemble de la
filière de levier peuvent être activés
pour améliorer leur compétitivité
la réduction des charges sociales et la
contractualisation
le chantier de l'allègement des charges
sociales et fiscales dans le secteur de
la forêt et des industries de bois est
largement engagée avec le pacte de
responsabilité et les forces poursuivra
en 2016 et 2017 pour être porté à 598
millions d'euros en 2010 cette donne 19
219 millions d'euros de crédits d'impôt
compétitivité emploi
la contractualisation entre
propriétaires forestiers publics et
privés les entreprises de transformation
doit permettre de réduire les temps de
prospection de sécuriser les
approvisionnements et de limiter les
variations de prix
c'est une des actions promu par le
contrat stratégique de filière bois avec
l'intervention de médiateurs
donc oui le gouvernement
est mobilisé pour que les scieries
artisanale puisse continuer à exister à
se développer de nouveaux après des
années bien difficile ilan et la
nécessité pour nos massifs forestiers
pour nos territoires forestiers et
également pour l'ensemble de l'économie
de proximité
merci madame la présidente à 30 secondes
merci madame la ministre pour cet
encouragement pour ses scieries
artisanale qui sont indispensables sur
notre territoire car oui aujourd'hui
avec la fin de l'exploitation des bois
de tempête les industriels papetier
recours pour leur approvisionnement à
berlin brut ou des billions de sciage
qui viennent déstabiliser
l'approvisionnement des petites scieries
et le déséquilibre annoncé entre
ressources et demande entraîné une
hausse des prix du bois qui impacte
directement les industriels de la
filière et pénalise justement
directement les scieries dans les
capacités financières sont limitées par
rapport à des grands groupes pas petit
internationaux alors oui madame la
ministre la syrie et ses petites
scieries ont besoin de soutien à leur
profession c'est une priorité et merci
pour l'attention que le gouvernement
pour apporter à ce domaine économique et
qui joue un rôle extrêmement important
dans nos territoires ruraux
merci madame la présidente la parole est
notre collègue michel le scouarnec pour
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mais sa
collecte depuis plusieurs années notre
forêt fait l'objet de spéculations sans
que personne ne semble appréhender
réellement la mesure des dégâts
occasionnés
en effet la forêt devenu une valeur
refuge qui suscite beaucoup d'appétit de
la part des investisseurs privés qui
n'ont que peu de considération pour
l'écosystème forestier autant fragile
cela touche en particulier les massifs
de résineux ainsi en les couvrant en
monoculture avec des essences comme le
douglas dont la rentabilité phoque
il y à un véritable risque de voir se
mettre en place une baisse systématique
de la responsabilité des forêts mais
aussi une atteinte à la biodiversité
pourtant notre forêt représente un atout
majeur pour notre pays avec la mise en
oeuvre de la transition énergétique
il ne faut pas omettre aussi la
potentialité de ressources
supplémentaires pour les exploitants
agricoles dont la transformation
moi peut être largement valorisés à
travers la construction les chaufferies
bois les plaquettes tout cela contribue
à l'aménagement du territoire à la
beauté des paysages et à l'amélioration
de la qualité de vie de plus des élus ne
peuvent faire face aux opérations
d'acquisition menée par les fonds
d'investissement qui contournent la
législation notamment le droit de
préférence mises en place pour lutter
contre le morcellement de la forêt
privée
or le plafond de 4 hectares ne
s'applique sur la totalité de la
superficie de toutes les parcelles
vendues
ainsi si l'ensemble fait plus de 4
hectares le droit de préemption ne
s'applique pas notre forêt a besoin de
maîtrise pour toutes ses composantes de
la production à la diversité des
essences en passant par les coûts elle
est une richesse nationale qui ne doit
pas être accaparée par les grands
groupes nationaux voire internationaux
ou par des pays tels la chine et le saut
commerce des grumes de bois
dommage que l'état se désengage de la
gestion forestière en imposant le wave
des contraintes financières
disproportionnées et d'émissions éloigné
de sa vocation première
c'est pourquoi je vous demande quelles
mesures vous comptez prendre pour
protéger la multifonctionnalité de la
forêt française dans son ensemble
madame la ministre pour répondre aux
menaces que le scouarnec
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur le scouarnec
comme je viens de l'indiquer dame en
réponse au sénateur joël labbé la
gestion forestière durable constitue le
socle d'autres politiques
je les ai rappelés pour l'instant force
est de constater que seul le bois et la
chasse à sur la quasi totalité du
financement de la forêt alors que la
préservation et la valorisation de ce
patrimoine forestier dicte notre action
la forêt métropolitaine
aujourd'hui dans sa grande majorité
d'une belle endormie dans ces conditions
une exploitation forestière plus
instance ne représenteraient en rien une
menace pour les écosystèmes forestiers
on ne prélève en moyenne que 40 à 50 %
de l'accroissement annuel de la forêt et
en forêt privée nous sommes que de 20 à
30%
autant dire que le capital forestier
continue de croître dans bien des cas ce
n'est pas souhaitable tant pour la
secrète séquestration du carbone dans
des peuplements arrivé à maturité que
pour le renouvellement et l'adaptation
des forêts au dérèglement climatique et
cela sans parler des risques d'un stade
étaient des peuplements en cas de
tempête comme ce fut le cas en 1999 et
dix ans plus tard la gestion forestière
doit être dynamique respectueuse de la
biodiversité
il n'y a selon nous aux connais aucune
incompatibilité entre ses enjeux je vous
rejoins toutefois dans le constat de
certaines dérives qui conduisent à faire
de nos forêts les refuges fiscaux
cinquantaine des services économiques
sociaux ou environnementaux ne soient
rendus à la nation
des contrôles seront prochainement
lancés pour vérifier l'effectivité de la
gestion forestière engagements pris par
les propriétaires forestiers en
contrepartie des réductions fiscales
accordées réductions de droits de
mutation réduction d isf des bulles
spéculatives sur la valeur des forêts
sont actuellement constatés en lien avec
certains avantages fiscaux de la loi
tepa la forêt certains biens privés pour
75 % de sa surface mais je vous rejoins
totalement sur ce point elle représente
également
je dirais même surtout un patrimoine
commun qui ne peut être considérée comme
un régime fiscal concernant les autres
questions que vous avez posé je vous
propose à ce moment là d'un rendez vous
car il ya une technicité à vous apporter
dans des délais qui ne peuvent être
tenues trop les deux minutes sur ce
corner
merci d'un ministre donc votre réponse
ne satisfait pas partiellement parlant
gestion durable du capital à valoriser
des gros efforts qui restent à faire
cela est vrai je voudrais donc ajouter
certains éléments qui mériterait d'être
accentué comme le renforcement du droit
de préférence des riverains afin de
valoriser leurs groupements forestiers
chaque propriété ou parcelles devraient
faire l'objet d'un droit de préférence
quelle que soit sa superficie de même il
semble qu'il serait important d'ailleurs
d'élargir encore le droit de préemption
les safer pour passer le boisé ou
d'octroyer aux également aux communes
forestières un droit de pardon un droit
de préemption
je serai des premiers éléments de
réponse face à la spéculation pour
laquelle les acteurs locaux sont
totalement désemparé cela un pic à
chaque vague les communes les affaires
soient informés enfin il est nécessaire
de mettre en place un véritable service
public qui englobe les propriétaires
publics et privés un contrôle
indépendant de l'exploitation des forêts
domaniales et un financement pérenne de
la gestion forestière afin de réguler
l'exploitation et la fonction
du long terme et de l' équilibre de la
forêt merci merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à une forestière
d'ailleurs madame anne catherine loisier
pour le groupe union des démocrates et
indépendants sur karoutchi est aussi
forestier merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
ma question porte sur l'avenir de l'eau
nf du régime forestier de la gestion
durable des forêts publiques françaises
en août dernier l'état unilatéralement a
remis en cause le contrat d'objectifs et
de performance 2012-2016 convenu avec le
nf et les communes forestières
il manque 50 millions d'euros pour
redresser les comptes de l'eau nf bercy
envisage donc un financement
supplémentaire des communes en proposant
de porter la participation de 2 euros
par hectare institué en 2012 à 14 euros
et d'augmenter les frais de garderie de
12 à 18%
face aux protestations des élus des
communes forestières le gouvernement
recule et renvoie une renégociation
aujourd'hui ces discussions sont dans
l'impasse le gouvernement semble ne pas
avoir renoncé à faire payer davantage
les communes aient choisi même de placer
un intérimaire à la tête de l'eau nf
pour gérer au mieux la négociation en
cours
il n'est pire sourd que celui qui ne
veut pas entendre titrait le président
de la fédération nationale des communes
forestières dans son dernier édito pour
témoigner de son dépit madame car trop
c'est trop
dans un contexte de baisse des dotations
les communes forestières n'en peuvent
plus elles ont déjà fait des efforts
financiers considérables en 2012
aujourd'hui elles sont prêtes à
redéfinir le cadre du régime forestier
envisager de nouvelles méthodes de
gestion plus économe mais c'est halo nf
de maîtriser ses dépenses de
fonctionnement une économie réaliste de
2% suffirait pour cela il est urgent de
mettre en pratique les préconisations de
la cour des comptes
appliquez une véritable comptabilité
analytique de toutes les dépenses et pas
seulement de celle des communes revoir
la gestion des ressources humaines 475
équivalents temps pleins supprimés entre
2009 et 2011
et pourtant une masse salariale qui
explose de 10 millions d'euros
recentrer les investissements des
filiales concurrentiel sur les seules
opérations rentables
un critère de bon sens si l'on cherche
encore madame la mine
imposer des charges supplémentaires et
injuste aux communes forestières elle ne
signerons pas ce contrat et elles
chercheront à se désengager de ce régime
forestier à la veille de la coop 21
il serait dommage d'en arriver à une
telle extrémité face aux enjeux de
mobilisation de ressources renouvelables
sur lesquelles nous venons de voter dans
le cadre de la loi de transition de
gestion multifonctionnelle commence
sollicités nous pouvons faire de la nf1
outils modernes de gestion garant d'une
stratégie forestière nationale est en
capacité de mobiliser cette ressource la
quatrième d'europe
madame la ministre dans ce contexte
comment comptez-vous créer les
conditions d'un nouveau contrat de
gestion des forêts publiques intégrant
les besoins du marché les attentes
sociales la nécessaire préservation de
l'environnement mais aussi et surtout
les finances des collectivités
merci merci pour vous répondre la parole
et à madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice loisier avant toute
chose je tiens à réaffirmer
l'attachement du gouvernement au régime
forestier fondée sur la gestion des
forêts et les collectivités par l'office
national des forêts si les forêts
publiques ne représentent qu'un quart de
la surface boisée métropolitaine louer
nef commercialise 40% du volume des bois
c'est en cela un acteur clé de la
filière forêt bois en 2013 le coût net
de la gestion des forêts des
collectivités s'est élevé à 115 millions
d'euros
les collectivités ont contribué à
hauteur de 15% au financement de ce coup
au travers des frais de garderie sur la
base des recettes tirées de leurs forêts
et une contribution forfaitaire à
l'hectare de forêts gérées 2 euros par
hectare en 2014 l'état a augmenté de 20
millions d'euros lé versement
compensateur pour le porter à 140
millions d'euros dans le cadre du
triennal 2015-2017 l'objectif de
réduction des déficits publics avait
conduit le gouvernement à augmenter
progressivement la contribution des
communes forestières pour atteindre 50
millions d'euros en 2010 est la forte
opposition des communes forestières a
conduit à anticiper la révision du
contrat d'objectifs et de performance
d'établissement qui devait prendre fin
en 2016 il faut noter que dès sa
première application
2012 les hypothèses sous-jacentes à
scott se sont révélés très ambitieuse
voire peu réaliste l'état d'ailleurs
contribué à hauteur de 5 millions
d'euros au delà de ce qui était prévu
dans le propre
en 2015 le nf intégrera la baisse de 20
millions d'euros prévus le niveau des
ventes de bois de 2014 et des économies
de gestion et pourvoir ans je me permet
quand même de rappeler les efforts qui
ont été faits ces dernières années par
louer nef et ils ont participé fortement
à la réduction des dépenses publiques
en fait les travaux sont d'ores et déjà
engagées entre les signataires du coq
pour préciser les objectifs et les
moyens qui seront assignés à
l'établissement pour la période
2016-2020 et nous continuons à
travailler bien entendu en concertation
mais les communes forestières pour avoir
un dispositif adapté et soutenable merci
madame la ministre
chers collègues dans trente secondes il
s'agit bien entendu nous arrivons à
trouver un
un mode d'organisation qui satisfera
l'ensemble des partis parce que les uns
comme les autres les communes
forestières comme état nous sommes
effectivement attaché à ce régime
forestier
il faut vraiment que chacun est que nos
gouvernements prennent conscience que la
forêt française est exceptionnel c'est
la quatrième forêts d'europe pas sa
surface et la troisième forêt d'europe
par son volume de bois pure sur pied
c'est aussi une fois exceptionnel ça a
été dit par sa diversité par la gestion
durable que les acteurs forestiers ont
mis en oeuvre depuis des années et c'est
un formidable potentiel d'emplois que
nous nous devons aujourd'hui compte tenu
de la situation économique du pays
d'exploiter et le mot convient
particulièrement d'exploiter d'optimiser
et la parole et à d'autres collectifs le
roi pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
mais c'est encore des forêts monsieur le
président madame la ministre je veux
d'abord remercier la la cour des comptes
est la commission des finances qui ont
établi à un excellent rapport un très
bon diagnostic sur la forêt et ce à la
demande du groupe d'études de travail
forêt bois du sénat le rapport que qui
nous est présenté aujourd'hui doit être
nuancée dans la nuance est dans ses
applications en effet le rapport
rappelle fort aux purs opportunément
que la forêt française est
essentiellement feuillus et très peu
résineuses et qu'en fait aujourd'hui les
usages des sillages feuillus ont disparu
en grande partie et que nous sommes donc
déficitaire antiâge résineux et ça c'est
une constante
une réalité qui s'impose à nous pour 10
ou 20 ans ou 30 ans encore et est ce que
ça soit encore une réalité
le marché aura peut-être changé dans 100
ans le résultat aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
accuse la filière forêt bois française à
tort d'un déficit considérable les 6
milliards de déficits sans lier pour une
grande partie au fait que nous sommes
aujourd'hui en excédent de sciage
feuillus que nous savons pas utilisé est
en déficit de sciage résineux
il faut se méfier de diagnostic enfin ou
de conclusion qui oublieraient cette
évidence deuxième évidence la cour des
comptes rappelle fort opportunément que
les les milliards les milliards qu'on
donne à la forêt n'existe pas on donne à
peine à peine 900 millions à la forêt et
donc ça c'est important je rappelle que
la forêt française ne coûte pas cher
monsieur le ministre
madame la ministre le gouvernement a mis
en oeuvre le fonds forestier le foin
stratégique forestier allez-vous le
doter de façon constante et sur des 100
à 120 millions dont la forêt a besoin
pour assurer son renouvellement et
assurer sa bonne mobilisation
vous avez fait l'effort sur le budget
actuel de mobiliser 60 millions 30 + 30
il en manque madame le ministre 100
millions
sans cette assurance des 107 assurance
de 100 à 140 millions par an ce qui
n'est rien pour les 15 millions
d'hectares de la forêt française 107
conclure les politiques forestières ne
pourront pas se mettre en oeuvre chers
collègues beaumont réponse la parole est
à madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur en effet vous avez
relevé l'importance d'avoir une forêt
qu'ils soient bien gérées et dont nous
devons mesurer pleinement l'apport de la
forêt à l'ensemble des activités
économiques sur les territoires mais
également l'apport à l'aspect
environnemental et social que nous
devons développer
il est nécessaire de rappeler que ce
gouvernement a pris pleinement
conscience des enjeux qu'il y avait sur
la forêt et nous avons mis en place
différents dispositifs comme je vous pu
vous l'indiquez des dispositifs sur des
gouvernances une interministérielle it
est renforcée mais également des moyens
financiers car comme vous l'avez indiqué
toute stratégie n'est valable que si
elle est soutenue par des crédits
budgétaires
bien sûr vous rappeler que le fonds bois
2 est en cours de constitution et nous
avons déjà 25 millions d'euros assuré à
travers bpi france et les consultations
qui sont en cours avec les financeurs
privés sont de bon augure
et je pense que nous allons pouvoir vous
annoncer dans les prochains mois et
stéphane le foll pour le dire à des
montants significatifs qui seront
mobilisés mais également avec la
création du fonds stratégique de la
forêt et du bois dans la ville up
atteindre à terme 30 millions d'euros et
qui sera bien entendu mobilisées et qui
sera après permettra d'être pérennisé si
nous voyons qu'il ya une bonne dynamique
qui s'engagent sera aussi renforcée par
l'extension du fonds chaleur à la
mobilisation du bois énergie comme je lé
indiqué tout à l'heure pour la première
année pour la première fois 30 millions
d'euros de ce fonds chaleur sera en fait
dirigé pour permettre l'alimentation en
amont de tous les dispositifs qui sont
nécessaires nous devons favoriser bien
entendu les moyens de chauffage par le
bois il faut être certain qu'il y ait
une bonne alimentation
et puis également avec le compte
d'investissements forestiers
et d'assurance nous ferons en sorte avec
des incitations fiscales significative
que l'investissement patrimonial soit
menée de façon active et que la coupe
l'entretien en fait la production de
bois présente sur un aspect fiscal
également un dispositif vous rappeler
également que sur les crédits du feader
il faut que nombreux de nombreux
programmes sont fléchés sur le bois est
également dans les déclinaisons
régionales
dp drh il y aura également des
mobilisations de crédit par les régions
sur l'aspect bois qui compléteront les
dispositifs majeurs mis en place par
l'état
merci très rapidement monsieur philippe
leroy très très rapidement mais il me
reste encore 20 secondes au moins
j'aurai simplement dire la mise méar je
reconnais je reconnais la bonne volonté
du gouvernement mais c'est du bricolage
excusez-moi j'exagère peut-être mais
c'est du bricolage vous nous alors qu'il
nous faut
l'assurance d'avoir constamment pendant
les 10 ou 15 prochaines années
parce que la forêt ça se raisonne pas
d'année en année l'assurance que nous
pourrons bénéficier des 100 à 150
millions nécessaires à l'amélioration à
la mobilisation de la forêt vous nous
apportez en toute bonne volonté mais des
solutions de bric et de broc 30 millions
par 6 10 millions par la case et jamais
assurer de la pérennité
madame la ministre nous vous demandons
de la pérennité pour donner la confiance
aux acteurs de la forêt du bois de façon
à ce que nous puissions avancer
merci mon cher collègue la parole est là
notre collègue yannick botrel pour le
groupe socialiste
deux minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues il y à un mois
précisément avec mon collègue alain
houpert nous rendions public au nom de
la commission des finances un rapport
d'information sur les soutiens publics à
la filière forêt bois française ce
rapport faisait suite à une enquête
demandée par notre commission à la cour
des comptes à la suite de sa publication
nous avons souhaité attirer l'attention
du gouvernement et des différents
ministères concernés en particulier sur
la question de la gouvernance de la
filière
en effet la réflexion stratégique sur ce
que devraient être les priorités de la
politique forestière française est
insuffisante
cette situation conduit donc trop
souvent un saupoudrage des crédits
publics ce qui ne permet ni d'être
performant ni d'être efficient la mise
en valeur et l'exploitation efficace et
raisonnée de la forêt devrait faire
consensus
dès lors comment cet objectif se
traduit-il en termes de politiques
publiques par exemple en matière de
reboisement ce qui concerne la mon car
il s'agit là selon moi d'un enjeu
fondamental nécessitant des réponses
politiques rapides mais également en
matière de balance commerciale en ce qui
concerne l'aval à cet égard je veux
préciser un aspect de notre rapport qui
a pu être mal compris nous ne souhaitons
pas à mettre à mal la filière bois
énergie nous nous interrogeons sur les
limites des soutiens apportés à cette
sous filières qui dans certains cas mais
aucunement de manière générale entraîne
des tensions sur les ressources et des
conflits d'intérêts qui peuvent affecter
d'autres acteurs de la filière
plus globalement celle équilibre des
soutiens publics entre les différents
acteurs de la filière qui fait l'objet
d'interrogations et donc attend des
réponses en ce qui concerne la
gouvernance
quelles sont les dispositions concrètes
que le gouvernement souhaite mettre en
oeuvre pour la rendre plus adapté et
plus efficace tant en ce qui concerne
l'état a traversé ministère que les
acteurs professionnels eux mêmes dans
l'objectif de mieux conduire les
politiques publiques dont la filière
bois a besoin enfin madame la secrétaire
madame la ministre
ma question est à la fois simple dans
l'énoncé est complexe dans la
déclinaison des réponses quelles
initiatives voulez vous porter
rapidement pour développer la filière
forêt bois pour aujourd'hui bien entendu
et pour préparer demain
merci la parole de tamada mme la
ministre pour répondre à monsieur botrel
la parole oui merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur botrel la
loi l'avenir pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et la forêt et répondent
je pense à vos attentes
en premier lieu le programme national de
la forêt du bois est en cours
d'élaboration par l'ensemble des acteurs
de la filière forêt bois
il sera décliné en programmes régionaux
sous la double tutelle de l'état et des
régions acteurs économiques clés du
développement de la filière bois en
matière de crédit je passerai rapidement
je les ai déjà développé alors l'avenir
a créé le fonds stratégique de la forêt
et du bois
nous avons également sur le fond la
chaleur une enveloppe mobilisés pour la
biomasse forestière est de plus un appel
à manifestation d'intérêt a été lancé
par l'ademe en lien étroit avec le
ministère de l'agriculture et de la
forêt pour une mobilisation accrue du
bois énergie rappeler que cette
initiative conjointe avec l'ademe a été
couronnée de succès par car plus de 60
millions d'euros de projets ont été
identifiés et les projets définitifs
seront sélectionnés au second semestre
en fait le gouvernement est soucieux
d'associer étroitement les acteurs
professionnels de la filière aux choix
stratégiques notamment cavale les
commissions régionales de la forêt et du
bois seront redéfinies le décret est en
cours dans le sens d'une participation
élargie des acteurs de l'aval de la
filière sous la double présidence état
région le programme national de la forêt
du bois en cours d'élaboration
c'est déclination régional et le contrat
stratégique signée par quatre ministres
constitueront le cadre qui permettra
pour les années futures d'avoir une
action publique de la forêt bois donc
gouvernance financement mobilisation
soutien à l'ensemble des acteurs amont
et aval permettront d'assurer un
investissement forte qui n'a jamais eu
lieu durant les dix dernières années sur
secteur
merci madame la ministre le sénateur
merci madame la ministre de votre
réponse je rappellerai que ce rapport
portait en effet sur une période qui
s'achevait en 2013 pour autant l'enjeu
économique est important cela a été
rappelé pour un déficit du commerce
extérieur
la balance du commerce extérieur de 60
milliards la forêt pèse pour 10
milliards il ya donc un enjeu économique
important
il faut ensuite avoir je pense au coeur
de nos politiques
l'anticipation nécessaire parce que à
segments de la filière filière bois
emballages légers nous alerte dès
maintenant sur un risque de pénurie de
la ressource à horizon 15 en clair les
plantations de peupliers et puis enfin
sur l'organisation du gouvernement
dans tous les cas de l'état cinq
ministères qui jouent chacun leur
partition pour étendirent peut conduire
parfois à la cacophonie il faut donc
qu'un chef d'orchestre s'imposer sur ce
point les initiatives du gouvernement
sont attendus
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue henri cabanel pour le groupe
socialiste avait la parole et monsieur
le président merci à madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le 22 avril dernier
votre collègue stéphane le foll a réuni
pour la cinquième fois le conseil
supérieur de la forêt et du bois
l'objectif du gouvernement est très
clair co rédigé avec la filière le
programme national de la forêt et du
bois dans une démarche de nécessaire
politique inter régionale et de
prospective à 10 m les défis sont
nombreux dans un contexte de réformes
institutionnelles débouchant sur un
nouveau paysage territorial la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique la
baisse de la dépendance énergétique
le soutien à l'emploi non délocalisable
la mise en exercer des circuits courts
ces chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes france
la filière bois représente et 5000
emplois et 300 mètres cubes de bois
valoriser équivalents emplois non
délocalisables
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement via la
loi d'avenir s'est unie aux
collectivités et à l'europe pour mettre
en avant le bois dans la construction
avec le projet sans constructions
publiques à moi locales fortement relayé
par la fédération nationale des communes
forestières à mi-parcours cette
initiative est une réussite car les
collectivités ont compris qu'elles ont
un rôle majeur à jouer en optant pour
cette ressource locale tente au niveau
de la structuration de la filière au
niveau du développement économique de
leur territoire
à ce titre le département de l'hérault
s'est distingué en obtenant en 2014 le
prix national de la construction bois
avec la salle de spectacle
nous le théâtre jean claude carrière la
filière bois fait partie des tracts
quatre filières d'avenir identifié par
le gouvernement qui viennent récemment
de signer le contrat filière bois il
s'agit de signes forts pour cette
filière est pourtant affaibli par la
concurrence mondiale face aux efforts
constants de cette filière les démarches
certification des investissements
consacrés chaque année à l'innovation
dans la modernisation de l'outil de
production par les industries de la
transformation du bois
quels moyens envisagez vous pour
soutenir les collectivités territoriales
qui font l'objet de l'option du bois
dans leur construction
quelles aides incitatives particulières
peuvent être mises en place pour
favoriser la solution bois il est
elle-même dubois fera et c'est dans la
construction de logements sociaux dans
la parole est à mme la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur cabanel vous avez
raison le développement de l'utilisation
du bois dans la construction est un
levier majeur sinon le principal pour le
développement de l'ensemble de notre
filière bois différents leviers peuvent
être actionnés pour valoriser les bois
français en premier lieu il faut
signaler initiatives du secteur privé
qui vient de proposer un label bois
français il est cependant difficile
d'envisager des aides directes aux
collectivités locales pour soutenir la
construction en bois qui comporterait de
nos risques de contentieux
le conseil constitutionnel a récemment
annulé le décret de 2010 sur les seuils
minimum d'incorporation du bois dans la
construction
en revanche l'état met en oeuvre des
programmes d'action notamment dans le
cadre du contrat stratégique de filière
qui ne vise pas le soutien de la demande
mais l'organisation de l'offre
c'est ainsi que le plan bois
construction 2 pour la période 2014 2017
porté par le ministère du logement se
décline autour de trois axes
stratégiques formation en pro
compétences valorisation des feuillus
dans la construction positionnement des
solutions bois sur le marché de la
réhabilitation de logements
en outre le plan de la nouvelle france
industrielle que vous avez site est
également en cours de déploiement est
porteur d'une grande ambition pour cette
filière d'avenir
à noter qu'ils convient de rester
vigilant afin d'éviter qu'un
développement des usages du bois dans la
construction développement qui serait
trop brutale ne fasse le lit
d'importations massives
c'est pourquoi nous cherchons en
parallèle à ce que ce marché puisse
mieux s'appuyer sur la mobilisation de
la ressource forestière nationale
des travaux sont également engagés sur
la commande publique afin de mobiliser
les grandes entreprises publiques et
privées via la commande publique et
soutenir ainsi les films les entreprises
de la filière forêt bois le tout grâce à
des mesures de simplification et de
définition des critères de performance
pour la sélection de l'offre en
parallèle une formation accrue des
maîtres d ouvrage le secteur bois sera
donc pleinement prises en compte dans
les modifications apportées au code des
marchés publics à venir dans une
ordonnance prévue pour le mois prochain
et pour cette dernière question
vertement permettez moi monsieur le
président de rappeler que la politique
gouvernementale sur la soutien à la
filière bois voudrait que la citation de
châteaubriant ne s'applique pas c'est à
dire que les forêts précède les peuples
et les déserts les suivent
nous voulons que le peuple et la forêt
puissent coexister ensemble de façon
bien sûr durable sur tous les aspects
économiques sociales et
environnementales
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
sénateur pour répondre à châteaubriant
merci merci madame heures la ministre de
ces de ces précisions
bon il faut savoir qu'effectivement les
collectivités ou les bailleurs sociaux
on est un petit peu refroidi par le coup
de ce que pouvait représenter la
construction bois mais évidemment depuis
les années 60 et 15 ce coût a diminué
pour aujourd'hui être équivalent à une
construction parpaings et je crois que
le meilleur exemple que l'on doit donner
c'est la force publique qui doit le
donnait en se lançant dans la
construction bois et notamment parce que
on sale leur frilosité chez les
bailleurs sociaux qui ont des
difficultés à se lancer dans cette
démarche et madame la ministre je
voulais vous remercier de votre
participation à cette séance de
questions qui est madame la ministre mes
chers collègues par lettre en date de ce
jour le gouvernement demandant
l'application de l'article 48 alinéa 3
de la constitution